[Music]
in celebrity catfish news submitted by
fedoraboys a woman was conned out of
$130,000 by G's by a Jason Statham
imposter oh why Jason Statham of all
people he's so sexy that all girls want
a [ __ ] maybe that's all maybe that's
all he could look like and he's like
well if I'm gonna be in a possible
second this is happening to everyone but
not everyone is gold bolt as this woman
because they dumb weren't you I was you
could say Dom we don't know her so she
yeah we don't know her because she wants
to remain [ __ ] dumbass I'd be
embarrassed you guys watch that movie
ten or not tag-team night yeah where she
[ __ ] she thinks she was the funniest
moment in that film did what the widest
knows everything I was in tears laughing
a picture popped up that [ __ ] was hella
funny she had that picture all along and
she couldn't compare it to it cuz we
even us was like while you watching
movie you're like it does it kind of
looks like him but you think it's part
of the movie and then you find out it
wasn't even him you're like perfect guy
okay yeah so this British woman she says
she was scammed out of a hundred and
twenty nine thousand dollars her vagina
got the best of her yep so she said that
she had been browsing on Facebook and
she came across a fan page dedicated to
Jason Statham so she like joined it or
whatever and then she was bombarded by a
string of flirtatious messages from him
what are you doing tonight and so she
said oh like she thought that oh that's
nice of him he's talking to his fans and
then that she might have been starstruck
that she doesn't know but what ended up
happening is that they continue talking
and then under a false sense of security
she agreed to his suggestion of sending
him money because he said that there was
like a movie that was being delayed and
that people out had owed him money
and so what would jason statham need
money from his fan I know what does that
mean a false sense of security what does
that mean I guess because she thought
that it was really him she trusted oh I
see I see and it links her to him like
now they get to keep talking yeah oh my
god you seem talking to me I feel like
people that fall for these things they
want it to be real so bad that they just
walk into these traps yeah is that in
the wax museum he's made out of wax
museum he's ready to [ __ ] all the time
it looks like he's about to do a APPL
speech yeah so then like this is one of
the messages it says send me a selfie of
you I would love actually you want to
read it cuz you could have a good
British accent send me a selfie of you
I'd love to get it very then he says I
would love together very very decent
smiles from your face right now
get a very decent smile that's not even
probably written hahaha will you you
would never text selfie yeah that words
key for him Jason Statham you know he
plays an actor in movies right like he's
acting he had every movie he's the same
person which means that's him and that's
to me he can't say felt selfie I would
love to see an interview and he's hella
flamboyant actually when I was doing
that build I was like transporter was
crazy I had to run so much you guys
wouldn't believe how much Ronnie had to
do I like broke a nail yeah so he says
well you love me you'd be the special
woman be honest and for the rest of your
life honey I really need you to do this
for me honey because I can't trust
anyone but you with my money honey
what's done Union website then you can
set up an account darling would never
say so 20 pounds 20,000 pounds these
British royalty this night and tomorrow
you do the same then by Friday it's
already done baby where are you I miss
you
talk to me baby baby where are you so
here just
me baby one more time I'm over this I'm
picturing you like a scam Center in
Nigeria and it's like some dude like
with the headset just typing it's really
broken English I picture like an Indian
news yeah yeah anything dudes those are
the ones that come into our DMS and they
[ __ ] ask for crazy really it's not
the Nigerian guys anymore not having no
it's all in the morn Adriaen princess
huh
dude this keeps happening to me like I
keep getting DMS of people saying like
hey what happened to your facebook I was
getting all these messages from you and
like oh yeah I've been like is this you
and oh yeah I get that the person keeps
making Facebook pages pretending I think
it's this one you just ignore them dudes
ignore them no what I end up doing at
that point is I post on on Instagram
like all my stories or something like
guys help me report this page I go yeah
because I'll try searching for it on
Facebook but it's not searchable like
person goes to my facebook page and
looks at who's following me and requests
all the people that are following me on
that Facebook page and then these people
like Phil ended up sending me messages
like Fedak like hey what happened we
were talking last night I'm like dude
this is not me like that's not my page I
only have that one page and it's already
been twice that I'm like damn what a
loser I I don't know if this person is
trying to do what this person did we're
just trying to get money out of people
maybe talking to you on Facebook just no
it's not it it's not it never talk to
you on facebook tip whatever to that
thousand dollars I gave you so this
person is claiming to have these very
intimate photos of me and it's like
photoshopped deep fakes
yeah like deep fakes and then like and
then people believe it or I'm like guys
come on how do you believe this and then
they'll send a wanna bid that that's why
it's like this scam girl they they want
to believe the fantasy is real like
maybe the body has like a [ __ ] Jota
two year and like here the like it's
gotta be to know I've seen some [ __ ] to
you yeah
but I'm like these people are disturbed
there's such losers it means deep fakes
of youtubers no I thought that was just
placed 1100 face to be I'm like my tits
are huge in that picture like I don't
have boobs really good the lighting will
be good too I like it when people take
pictures of other people and then they
send it to me and they're like I saw you
at the gym and I'm like that's not even
me why would I be in Virginia people see
me in different TV shows too and it's
always some like take a picture with the
ugliest fattest agent I've ever seen and
they go dude I saw you at the gym that
is the ugliest I've ever seen in my life
you know what the worst is when I see
Julia this [ __ ] t-shirt or mouth I
didn't want to look did you get sick
from Vegas
no I did so just try to be my fault
audio and then both Gio David start
laughing you might turn and she's like
[ __ ] dozed off I'm like [ __ ] you
that's not funny I love it when people
would like draw draw you guys and it's
like the most inaccurate drawing of your
face that's mercy in my life it's so far
the more the uglier it is the better
yeah like it's really beautiful but just
completely doesn't look like yeah yeah
I'm like thanks just like a Disney star
looking person Marius that's the best
yeah that shows a lot of love yeah it's
like I have no talent by all my express
stuff [ __ ] out of myself right now
that's me when I was eight not eight
years old these are adult stuff they'll
get better they keep practicing so then
this woman is saying that that money
represents a substantial amount which
would have made a difference through her
life and her family's okay what did you
why would you give it 100 is 3000 3 G's
yeah wait she has a family increment so
the person she didn't consult her
husband like do you think I should give
them some cuts on her husband did say
that her mother and her fiancee heavy on
me she had lost both of them Oh
their deaths aren't specified so we
don't know if it was recent but oh so
she was like she gives that away and
she's like you know I could have really
used that yeah so so I was very sad and
lonely [ __ ] who you are dude I'm not
giving you a hundred thirty thousand she
just needs her know a lot of the times
though when people are scammed I know
how scams work it happens because you're
greedy it happens because you want
something and then you get fooled yeah
you don't get some you don't get scammed
if you don't want something for nothing
right I mean even even guys that get
tricked with like
catfished and all that you you're you're
being lustful you're being horny you
want something you deserve you yeah
you're you're biting to that you're
biting that bait mm-hmm and all people
play victim it's like well it's like
those guys - every time you see a hot
girl you read that comment they're like
oh my god baby you're so beautiful I
would treat you so right yeah how one
has that ever [ __ ] working and you
click on their page and it's like see
free nudes every Thursday and Friday I'm
on I'm on the cams come come on that
only works like six times Dan mhm but
yes so they're looking for this guy and
obviously they haven't found them they
the only thing that they do know is that
it is overseas why would they the
scammers pick Jason Statham out of
everybody what are they doing out of
everyone that's what I was saying
earlier they just do this
doing it oh that's true [ __ ] scam
calls you know you know cuz after you
guys talked about it like the whole like
yeah you're somebody's kidnappers [ __ ]
they really do do that you got what yeah
why just picked it up cuz I was so
curious cuz most of times it's not that
it's more like oh the IRS type of thing
yeah I got the one where it was like a
person faking the whole well you got one
with a crying and stuff there was a
crime but they were frantic and then I
just responded good yeah they're like oh
my god I'm in such a I mean what the
[ __ ] what they mention a name at all I
know no this is very vague yeah I know
just like good I just it was real ya
know everybody knows like I care about
is somebody very closer they're all here
so it's like even for me if it's a real
one I just hang up on up really high
this as well as far I just want to talk
about this vessel oh good one buddy yeah
or go I block the credit called a credit
company that I applied with and then
they're about to reap all my piano
because I didn't come home that I got it
oh yeah and it all that holy [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] sorry sorry no no no I actually
got it but they kept trying to call me
and they're like if you don't freaking
answer we're gonna come over and repo
your people do you know that can they
break your door down and I've got a
nicely open the big they can't repo me
oh but they're just threatening in but
it worked cuz I was like oh what like
they've been trying to contact me
but I always think those things our
lives because last time they're trying
to collect student loan payments and I'm
like I never even had student loans yeah
lying ass [ __ ] I know I try to
get donations for the college I didn't
graduate from
[Music]
[Music]